[Music]
stay
put
tell me you got
[Music]
that
run
run may I use your phone nope but I need
to make a call I don't care
Mason what tell me why I should do a
favor for him well for example because
uh I can have you arrested for being a
foreign spy maybe I pull a coup on my
own then stop it
Mason singing dictators don't get to
sing really well then go ahead do it Mr
peti I am not afraid of death and I am
not afraid of people like you do
it
hey hey Put the gun down
please knock yourself out thank you
don't worry I'll make it
petite follow me follow
me go go you've been hit I'm fine go
with
[Music]
me see
[Applause]
fine come in we're safe here this is my
man
cave you care for a
drink yeah always love a single MTH
after knap a few
mercenaries come on Mason
embrace the
suck you're looking for
bagas here is
bagas um can you
ride I'm all
[Music]
right okay hold
up
get on what get on no no I am very
afraid on horses half of your pictures
are on horses this
photosop okay
okay let's
go I bought that one so Ellie and you
were roommates in the University yes our
second and fourth years yes
well any friends of Ellis is welcome in
Pia tell me about her how is she well
um she is very happy in Kansas I know
what's in Kansas anyway it's a rich
Rancher she
married not in Kansas anymore
huh a bad joke no the wizard of us it's
one of my favorite movies I should have
introduced you Mason is my protective
detail of course he is of course Mason
petites cdi's finest former Army Special
Forces
right the little
house we do our own research
too B
[Music]
El do you know that feeling when you're
doing EX exactly what you put on the
earth to do the one where it's like
everything inside you is moving together
in harmony with the
universe me neither but you know one can
hope
right wave to Mommy cuz she'll hate me
even more than she already does if you
don't I seem to recall you saying that
becoming a lawyer would only crush your
soul yeah it has I'm running a business
and right now that business is getting a
journalist Ina
palonia it's a oneoff no no and no who's
a journalist I have resigned my position
here at 20 grand says you
are welcome to bolog president fega so
nice to meet
you we must take a selfie um you
approve
great ow
what the hell just happened your one
man's security detail happened he's a
hero I'm with the president of a country
in the middle of a coup this is the
scoop of a lifetime you got to be alive
down the scoop of a lifetime we never
should have come let's go you can't just
leave
[Music]
him run
run ready to go I don't know how to stop
when you start at the bottom only way to
go is up I'm just doing my
job do you need
help get up again and I got to win I get
up again then I got to win what you
still excited to cover a coup less and
less
honestly where is
vas here is vas go for hey not the time
for coaching
man oh oh my
God Color Me impressed Mr Petit not
Petit at
all tell me you got that
[Music]
run
oh